I represent child activists I do hang
around tragedies looking for kids who
have it credit baby
you killed it at the [ __ ] UN you're
an animal
why are you crying honey oh okay No are
there cameras on you keep crying throw
yourself on the floor throw yourself on
the floor right now Malala left me for a
competitor you haven't heard her [ __ ]
name in two years and you never will
again
David hog won't take a [ __ ] meeting
I've seen 30 pairs of sneakers to his
dorm Jesus Christ
tell Malala she's got to come out as
non-binary she wants to eat now that's
the way it is nobody gives a [ __ ] about
land mines anymore it's all climate
climate is sexy climate and guns clean
water that hasn't been hot since the
[ __ ] late 90s
do people even [ __ ] drink water wake
the [ __ ] up I got the Covington kids and
Nathan Phillips on a reconciliation tour
opening felissa who is it Emma Gonzales
don't put her truth she's [ __ ] me for
the last time I had a booked at Davos
she got sick you get sick at Davos we
got a new version of the pol brothers
from Syria they're [ __ ] hilarious
they do pranks
one of them's missing an arm and they
they have fun with that it's great we
got a kid with a cleft lip but he's cute
I want hog at Madison Square Garden
people are turning in their gums and
crying to him they're handing of guns
over to him in there crying yeah this is
just Jason got a call from David yeah
just let him know that I called we
actually sends him stuff in the mail
over if you take a look at it it's tough
you sneakers and okay sure yeah we got a
kid right now he has no limbs he is
[ __ ] hilarious and he does a whole
bit about the refugee crisis you have no
idea how hard this kid is gonna hit when
he hits do you understand no limbs we
walk him out we put him in a seat and he
just [ __ ] goes man he just goes these
kids will own you one day I will make
sure of it they will [ __ ] it on you I
got a three year olds from
Iceland and Gummer he loves economics
he's talking about debt peonage I got
him at the World Bank in three weeks
[ __ ] you